20 seconds of logo wait these
are still sending Harry
back to live with abusive relatives five
movies in and honestly the
Hogwarts people are just as bad as
Voldemort in my book they might as well
have just beat Harry themselves hey
assholes
Dementors show up just as Harry's about
to serve this asshole cousin some
long-overdue justice that not a shape
Dudley can keep up with somewhat
athletic Harry while running even the
Harry Potter franchise ends up reduced
to cheap jump scares since when are you
able to keep a Patronus on retainer also
it's been two years learn how to make a
full fledged Patronus already the last
time you did it all you had to do was
realize that you've done it before
you remember during all that time travel
rigmarole from the third movie how'd you
know my audience while you were being
beaten and forced to live under the
stairs did you expect him to let you go
wandering around hello what is she
supposed to do with any evil magic
antagonists tries to attack Harry I
watched over Harry like you asked
Dumbledore but Lucius Malfoy cast a
spell I couldn't deflect with my wicker
basket who did this to you boy
considering a coverton's character in
this series it's amazing you didn't
already blame Harry the ministry has
received intelligence you performed the
Patronus charm in the presence of
knuckle however our intelligence did not
notice the two Dementors that would have
sucked your face off so you must've been
frivolously conjuring Patronus charm for
no reason you are hereby expelled
oh no Harry's been expelled from
Hogwarts how are they gonna fill the
next two hours of this movie and the
three movies after it how the did
the ministry find a witness to testify
to harry using magic outside a school in
this instance but not in any other
previous instances he's done it and
basically every other movie good guys
here to rescue Harry Potter decide to
silently creep him the out first
before revealing themselves Dumbledore
has persuaded the minister to suspend
your exposure pending a formal hearing
what don't call me Nymphadora don't call
me whatever you just called me cliche
don't like cranks if one of us has
killed and no one pay any attention to
the flying witches and wizards in the
middle of a neighborhood either so we
they don't have a chimney or a magic
boot or some to transport Harry
where it needs to go they just fly
around London and say if muggles see us
come okay so now you're just pissing me
off
I hope I don't see the Palace of
Westminster now
things London you know it could have
been even cooler than this a magic
building not in London that doesn't have
anything to do with a regular muggle
apartment building I've just wrapped my
head around platform 9 and 3/4 how do I
wrap my head around this Harry is still
amazed it like this dude did you not see
the tent in the last movie
jump-scare hug go to the Phoenix roll
credits
Dumbledore made us swear not to tell you
anything so wire Hermione and Fred privy
to this super secret knowledge that
concerns Harry was bad no
and the guy's been in like a thousand
adventures that no kid should ever have
to go through and he fought Baltimore
this secret is the most ridiculous thing
ever just now to use magic now does not
mean you have to win your wands out for
everything if use magic means have sex
then yes they do good I want to join if
Vogel's raising an army then I want to
fight I guess that's where the
conversation ended there was nothing
else to sort out after that
ha-ha-hilarious why do these wizards
even need to use the subway
again every person in London is
walking down streets far away from this
so they can't witness this telephone
elevated also man I just can't figure
out the physics of this thing there's an
entire extra floor of telephone booth
tucked up in the top of this telephone
booth we've said it before but magic
this complex makes you wonder why there
are such things as problems in the
wizard world use of magic chimneys makes
you wonder why Harry and mr. Weasley
didn't do this if the reason is here he
can't use magic then why was he allowed
to fly on a broom earlier in 2010 demos
these DS owls
find it because the rest of the magic
world still using owls also these magic
memos have to take the elevator to get
delivered he's explaining too easily
what Bill Murray said at the end of lost
in translation
so mrs. fig is what's known as a squib a
muggle born to wizard parents but the
ministry says muggles can't see
Dementors so why does anything she say
hold any weight at all the odds are
astronomical
someone in a fantasy movie about magic
says something is impossible because of
the odds Professor Dumbledore continues
to be addicted Harry even after helping
Harry nobody in this entire busy station
is sitting in the waiting room serious
risks his own life the mission and
Harry's life just to show him a picture
well Andy's gonna die at the end of the
movie so we need to add in some fluffy
bonding to inflate the sorrow for the
audience later thanks pilot courage
Harry pull yourself like always
which would be reasonable in a magic
movie but of course invisible horses are
pulling this carriage and now they have
to throw this only people who have seen
death can see them
rinkle into the story I can't see them
too hairy and a gang just happened to
meet a student that did not exist the
first for Harry Potter's and who also
has seen death and concede the thestrals
by the way is this the only way to get
to Hogwarts if to cram five students at
a time on the back of a wagon
finally the carriage moves but why
waited so long is anyone's guess means
the ministry's interfering at home oh no
you mean the government is telling a
school what to do that's just being
unheard of man I said of falling wrong
Harry Potter is addictive Ron's you
don't understand help us - well I would
but Dumbledore made me swear not to tell
you guess we're even now huh flying I'll
signifies the passage of time cliche we
call pest rose 43 minutes into this
movie what's the real conflict sure
Dolores Umbridge is a total whore and
some people don't like Harry but that's
what we call the B story a story hasn't
cropped up yet it can only be seen by
people who've seen dead and the
thestrals must have had a great life
being invisible then one dude or chick
who saw death suddenly stumbled upon
them and made them into carriage horses
curse the Americans get widely
criticized for the portions restaurants
serve and how much we waste food but the
Harry Potter universe is filled with
huge plates of uneaten food where does
it all go when the kids are done merely
your medieval methods professors would
never have this argument in the full
view of students in the middle of a
heavily trafficked area things at hoc
what's a far worse than I feared
why is she suddenly turning to address
the large group of eavesdropping
students to adjust the seriously falling
standards at Hogwarts School the
ministry's being portrayed as the bad
guys here but yeah
has anyone ever learned anything at that
school wand block you've been in this
post how long exactly oh that poor nice
Trelawney getting grilled over her
worthlessness I'd hate to see her go
that's racist Jesus I know they're
magical people but it opened courtyard
public shame firing there's no decency
here I thought all these people were
British for fuck's sake
professor whatever Dumbledore's reason
is for ignoring Harry he's unwittingly
creating a new Voldemort what the hell
is wrong with this guy also these
assholes couldn't have told them listen
Harry Dumbledore has to ignore you this
year because of a big scary important
magic thing that you'll learn more about
later but it definitely doesn't mean
that he hates you as it probably feels
when no one explains this to you taking
over the entire school so far this movie
should have been called Harry Potter and
the really really bad teacher nobody
liked have we ever seen these
kids sitting around just listening to
the radio news no we have not
because we have not as of yet needed
such a cheap way to have our main
characters learn crucial information oh
look he does use the fireplace phone
again I stand corrected but I do not
stand corrected on the fact that it's
still just an easy Dave's ex machina for
communication that comes and goes at the
whim of the writer also why is he a
hologram in the flames this time instead
of literally having his face composed of
embers and ash did the fireplace phone
get a massive upgrade and capability
over the summer so how did Sirius know
that Harry and his friends and no one
else would be in this room at this exact
moment Alda mom is this news hey we need
some kind of transition between scenes
here okay just have Baltimore whisper
Harry in the rain and then dissolve do
an establishing shot of the school
brilliant it's a true you can purchase
petronas chime yes I've seen it well I'm
a hurry I didn't know you could do that
how did you not know that the entire
magical kingdom has been gossiping about
Harry and his formal trial for using a
Patronus charm in front of a muggle this
entire school year wait you made them
all sign in ink and paper for a
clandestine magic training club which
way you go okay there's an obvious sin
of cliche bully behavior going on here
after five years of this place but I'm
not sure if I need to award it to the
bully characters or the screenwriter
require Oh ex machina the requirement
only appears when a person has to be a
lead of it and just always equip for the
Seekers needs so it's a holiday also
what was Neville's need he got bullied
by Crabbe and Goyle but he was in no
danger did Neville need a room to cry in
also are you seriously saying that no
one at the school are in this cast of
main characters has ever had a real need
of a room like this during any of the
previous four adventures because if so
you and how many people can walk to this
spot and get into this room without
being seen the school is under the
micromanaging eye of umbrage she somehow
misses this how can you practice a spell
and not have the spells effect happen
like do you start by saying wand Siri
this is just a practice spell there was
something like that
how are the magical forces supposed to
know you really don't mean it this time
as opposed to other times
Hermione's victory over Ron gets
celebrated as this woman conquers man
sort of thing but don't we already know
that Hermione is better than most of all
the rest of her fellow students built
faults for this is this the only hallway
wall in all of Hogwarts where
proclamations may be hung it's a fun gag
I suppose but this is the opposite of a
practical way to actually communicate
and remind students of many new rules
but didn't he just do that spell for her
neither of them set a spell word so how
did the wand know what was required of
it
wasn't it confused by having two masters
at once believing in yourself whoa Harry
have you thought about maybe dating this
girl right here I mean I like Joe and
Ginny Weasley as much as the next guy
but you might be overlooking someone
Thomas Neville reaches deep down to his
British roots and conquers India Twila
y'all Room of Requirement does not
furnish condoms Wow was it wet well this
movie got a whole lot more interesting I
will attempt to penetrate your mind you
will attempt to resist prepare yourself
I'm not gonna tell you how to resist but
resist damn you so wait is Snape still
in Harry's mind what the hell happened
Snape just not Kari and I said too next
Christmas
why mother did that how shall I run away
these movies in their tragic character
backstories everyone's got a sob story
Harry's parents died serious his mother
was abusive Hermione's parents are
muggles Ron's family is Bohr I just feel
so angry all the time
yeah you're 15 welcome to puberty Jesus
Hogwarts not have a sex ed curriculum so
these poor kids can understand their
bodies but a fresh air you know oh yes
as gamekeeper fresh air must be
difficult to come by whoa
Touche Dolores Umbridge would be amazing
at cinema since there's a storm coming
ari we get it Hollywood damn when the
storms come in movies it's foreshadowing
got it this is how you break people out
of Azkaban by killing 1/10 of its
population with a massive for no reason
explosion also Bellatrix Lestrange who
we just heard about a few minutes ago
somehow survives this massive explosion
in her sector sure walk toward the
source of that loud bang that just
destroyed a mirror a second ago
why didn't she just do this in the first
place also why couldn't Dolores just
find the rumor requirement by really
needing it which barely makes the room
appear and if it really is helping Harry
with Dumbledore's Army then why doesn't
have a defense spell against this very
kind of magic hey what's this we found
your secret room Harry and we've got
your girlfriend too
maybe they're saying she talked but it's
not like they didn't know where the room
was done mootools
Oh see and paper trail gets you every
time the doors style Wow way to take one
of the few black characters in these
movies and make them a walking
stereotype come on is this really how a
painting full of magic figures would
work when they hung these paintings did
they have to be extra-careful so the
people inside didn't slide out of the
picture
well he can or you have to lose well
then I must have nothing to lose right
about now
lady it's just bestest so what well sure
my knee if you don't interrupt maybe
he'll answer the question
hey where's tight gifts Hagrid why can't
you just tell us because this is a Harry
Potter movie and he's Hagrid I mean
those are the only two reasons I can see
Dumbledore gone I'll lightly be get in
the sack any day now didn't Umbridge
visit you and already do that couldn't
just leave him because because he's my
brother
dun dun dun also CGI brother is CGI it's
Ron serious everytime they see something
weird in the forest with Hagrid in one
of these films it's something that will
be hugely important later every single
time think you've gotten admira
you have no idea control your emotions
discipline your on iron so apparently
these lessons are like Luke believing in
the force or something there's really no
significant tip or trick to controlling
your mind you just have to do it Harry's
dad is a dick to Snape causing Snape to
be a dick to everyone forever Umbridge
has her entire wall covered with
youtube's recommended videos section
umbrage let yourself be fooled into
walking way out into the haunted woods
with the two students she's been the
most suspicious about from day one you
the thing Hagrid introduced this
never-before-seen character crop to
everyone just before they got in trouble
sorry I'm just not tell lies irony I had
a feeling that the Centaurs are going to
do to Dolores Umbridge what the sisters
tried to do to Andy Dufresne and
Shawshank it's that justice or gross
over compensation so how are we going to
get London we fly of course of course
but with Umbridge being taken prisoner
and probably much worse than that by
centaurs why don't you use the flu
Network now there is no one in charge at
Hogwarts anymore no one in London who
watches the sky for leisure notices this
bit random crystal ball with crucial
clues to the rest of the series just
happens to be found by Neville while
they search for Sirius we interrupt the
fifth harry potter installment to bring
you eyes wide shut
shut your eyes wide kids why the
disguise any reason for that
at all I hadn't read the prophecy out of
Baltimore know for sure that the visual
clues he gave Harry would send into the
Ministry of Magic offices can only be
retrieved by those about whom they are
made so that makes this large collection
of prophecies located in the Ministry of
Magic in a dark room where no one can
find them virtually worthless also this
story takes a page out of the prophecy
handbook by not explaining who makes
them who they're for or how a cue
you have to do give to me either Lucius
is lying about the whole prophecies can
be retrieved only by those who mount
whom they are made thing or he hooked up
this whole lie by telling Harry that
because this prophecy would be useless
in any hands other than Potter's none of
the rest of these movies would even need
to take place if Voldemort would just
let his Death Eaters kill Harry and
steal the prophecy this room is suddenly
Domino's Department of mysteries has a
convenient escape door that leads to a
precipitous drop for no reason other
than to escape falling crystal balls
unexplained magical spell stops their
fall and keeps them alive because
reasons bad guys waste time scaring kids
instead of killing them shocker right I
mean didn't you say it wouldn't work
like this or did that lie you pulled out
of your ass turn out to be true get away
from my son son hell yeah there's
nothing like a good old-fashioned punch
when the principles involved can perform
magic also meanwhile none of lucious's
friends do anything when Sirius shows up
and the order of the Phoenix new to show
up here in this room somehow this would
probably be exciting if I had any idea
what the is going on there are too
many characters moving too quickly many
of whom I never knew well at all to
begin with I don't know which spells
need words and which ones don't who
spells are more powerful than whose it's
just a bunch of noise Bellatrix is the
only Wizard which of the whole bunch
during this entire fight to remember the
killing curse she killed she deserves it
all de mort is right all so is this
where he has to be Luke Skywalker and
decide not to kill lest he become a
Baltimore himself I'm not buying that
for one second Dumbledore knew that
Bellatrix would kill serious Harry would
run after Bellatrix Voldemort would
appear in this very Hall so he took the
exact chimney he needed to take to
appear just in time
Electric's does not need to say where
she's going to make this chimney work
which as we all remember was a hilarious
aspect of the flue network back in
chamber of secrets hey Harry mind using
a spell maybe take out Baltimore right
now while he's occupied with Dumbledore
now this is thrilling this puts anything
in any of Lucas's prequels to shame this
is how you stage and film a big showdown
duel it's just too bad about the two
hours you had to sit through to get to
this moment
700 friends the power of love kills the
demon cliche also this is probably why
Snape was a poor instructor for that
whole get Voldemort out of your mind
training because he too suffers from
that you'll never know love or
friendship thing this movie is
indirectly addictive Snape
Oh Harry Potter so is Baltimore
protected by this mist that's flying
around because he's visible why doesn't
anyone kill him right now and if the
mist is protecting him why doesn't he
use this more often
ah you feel at any time I know how you
feel you can't possibly know how I feel
cliche by distancing myself from you it
might be more pretend reason for not
telling Harry obviously important
details is bull
Foles raising it on me then I want to
fight if this is your first night at
Fight Club have to fight
because you know deep down you deserve
to be punished back what I did one day
happen you how many in you
Georgie can be what would you say you do
here well was it my warm apple pie will
it blend that is the question glass dust
don't breathe this dead Padfoot I hope
you're all right it's starting to get
colder here winter is coming
I'll tell you about the yellow King
don't you want to know who he was
I know exactly who he was
it was the Batman besides the world
isn't split into good people in death
Easter this morning good guys you
realize that don't you I mean you
realize there aren't evil guys and
innocent guys it's just it's just it's
just a bunch of guys
this is it you have to do is give to me
and I can show you everything I can show
you
shining shimmering splendid